We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David p. This is a very unusual
voicemail and this, I don't know if this is
the same quote, voice actor who has called
before. They actually sound a lot like someone
who calls in or does characters on the Howard
stern show. Um, with some advice about why
I shouldn't bite my fingernails, which I don't
do. Take a listen to this
j root. I want to share repairable with you
and the team on why you are going to fight
your fingernails. You see, when I was a little
boy like you would produce a pack. I bit my
nails all the time. Often your Dwayne's dried,
you know, hyper activity. And eventually I
had to go to the doctor for corrective surgery
on my digits due to the damage I've done.
And when I got home, my mother said I should
have a special treat because I was in a bad
mood. You see? And she didn't know. I feel
better after a slice of whole wheat toast
with cream cheese. Wow. Sure enough in the
fridge there was no chin of green gs waiting
for me, but when I tried to open it up, I
couldn't do because of all those wrappings
on the tips of my digits and despite my efforts
I couldn't get to the sweet, sweet creechy
side. Yes. My bad habit of nail biting kept
me from being able to follow my toes, which
we sweet Korean g o and just let that be a
lesson to you. You do.
Yeah. There is something oddly captivating
about that. Now it does raise more questions
than it answers. Like for example, is that
a voice actor or what are they talking about?
Why do people think I bite my fingernails
because I don't, it's nothing that I've ever,
ever, ever done. I just don't, I don't, that's
not a problem I have. I'm not aware if that's
a problem producer pat has, but it's certainly
not one that I've noticed. But there are so
many questions I have about that and maybe
someday some of them will be answered. But
one of the primary questions is who thinks
to call into political political show with
a message like that? That is really a, the
the primary question that I have and I would
love to know the answer to it. We've got a
great bonus show for you today. Uh, Donald
Trump is now vowing to release a report on
his finances before the 2020 election. And
this is again, a red herring. And I'll explain
why on the bonus show. A commonwell Harris
is also apologizing for her response, uh,
um, uh, after backlash, uh, she was slurred
and her response upset the disability community.
And I'll tell you what
about it and much more. On today's bonus show,
two ways to get access, become a member@joinedpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David [inaudible], the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.